das hat die menschheit noch nicht
gesehen polarlichter auf dem jupiter und
den nordpol des wasserreichsten planeten
unseres sonnensystems aus der nähe jetzt
bei klicks um 2.10 fiction
die raumsonde juno der nasa hat neue
sensationelle bilder und tonaufnahmen
zur bodenstation geschickt auf den
bildern sind das erste mal polarlichter
und der nordpol des jupiter zu sehen
bevor wir uns diese bilder angucken und
die tonaufnahme anderen gibt es erst
noch mal ein paar grundlegende fakten
und die sind echt interessant und
rekordverdächtig über den jupiter
jupiter ist der massereichste planet in
unserem sonnensystem und von der sonne
aus gesehen der fünfte planet durch
seine extreme masse die mehr als dem 3
112 fachen der erde entspricht ist er
auch der mit der stärksten
anziehungskraft die wirkt dann zum
beispiel auf kometen und asteroiden
der durchmesser des planeten ist
ungefähr 11 fach so groß wie der der
erde das sind 142 1984 kilometer im
inneren des planeten ist der druck etwa
30 millionen mal stärker als auf der
oberfläche der erde
und obwohl er so groß und zu schwer ist
rät er sich in nur zehn stunden um die
eigene achse damit ist er der schnellste
rotierende planet im sonnensystem
interessant dabei ist dass jupiter
selbst keine feste oberfläche hat
trotzdem wird er vermutlich einen festen
kern aus gestein und eis haben von außen
sieht man aber nur die glasoberfläche
die gase bewegen sich in
entgegengesetzten richtungen dadurch
entstehen ziemlich starke wirbel und
stürme der größte davon ist der große
rote fleck ein anti zyklon der etwa
dreimal so groß ist wie unsere erde
warum der sturm eine rote oder eher
orange farbe hat das ist noch nicht
bekannt die größe hat allerdings in den
letzten jahren abgenommen der fleck
wurde wahrscheinlich zum ersten mal im
siebzehnten jahrhundert beobachtet ende
des 19 jahrhunderts wurde seine größe
mit einem durchmesser von 41 tausend
kilometern gemessen
schon die voyager sonden maß 1979 und
1980 an durchmesser von gerade mal etwas
mehr als 23.000 kilometern und das
weltraumteleskop hubble hat jetzt den
geringsten durchmesser fotografiert der
je gemessen wurde aktuell sind es 16
1500 kilometer und es werden jedes jahr
rund 1000 kilometer weniger wenn es so
weitergeht ist der wirbel
nach adam
diese in 16 jahren verschwunden jetzt
suchen die astronomen nach den ursachen
wahrscheinlich verändern kleine wirbel
die der große schluck die dynamik dort
wie das genau abläuft wollen die
wissenschaftler in den nächsten jahren
erforschen etwas langsamer geht es bei
der umrundung der sonne zu gange der
jupiter braucht etwa 4300 erdentage also
mehr als elf jahre um die sonne einmal
zu umkreisen die temperaturen auf dem
planeten liegen bei etwa minus 18 grad
celsius damit ist der jupiter in der
reihenfolge auch der erste planet der
keine temperaturen mehr im positiven
bereich hat zumindest im äußeren bereich
denn je weiter man in den jupiter
hineinschaut desto höher werden auch die
temperaturen in seinem kern herrschen
sogar temperaturen von 30.000 grad
celsius zu seine hohe anziehungskraft
konnte der jupiter viele trabanten in
seine umlaufbahn ziehen insgesamt sind
bisher 67 monde bekannt die drei größten
davon sind in europa und ganymed io ist
dabei der vulkanisch aktivsten körper im
gesamten sonnensystem
während es auf europa unter einer
kilometer dicken wassereis hülle eine
vielleicht 100 kilometer tiefen ozean
mit flüssigem wasser geht und selbst auf
gani med könnte es einen leicht
salzhaltige ozean unter der oberfläche
geben damit ist auch der größte mond des
sonnensystems auch der mond callisto ist
sehr interessant auf ihm wurden einige
grundbedingungen gefunden die leben
möglich machen könnten nämlich
kohlenstoff und stickstoff verbindungen
in seinem inneren soll es auch flüssiges
wasser gibt jupiter ist also wie er
merkt ein durch und durch besondere
himmelskörper die neuen aufnahmen der
raumsonde juno bestätigen dass auch
nochmal zum einen können wir das erste
mal den nordpol des jupiters aus 195
tausend kilometern entfernung betrachten
zum anderen ermöglichen die neuen
aufnahmen erstmals einen blick auf
polarlichter auf dem jupiter und
außerdem gab es da ja noch die
tonaufnahmen vom fünften planeten des
sonnensystems was er gleich hören werdet
sind schallwellen die jupiter ins all
schickte
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lass mir gerne einen daumen nach oben
und ein kostenloses abo dafür einfach
hier klicken
wenn ihr hier klick da kommt ihr zu
einem weiteren video in dem es weitere
sehr spannende ton aufnahmen aus dem all
zu hören gibt viel spaß dabei und
schreibt mir auch mal in die kommentare
ob und wenn ja welche ihr von den ganzen
fakten kannte und welche noch nicht und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran